que j'avais bien conscience de
l'interdit d'en parler quoi l'interdit
de la Cesse c'est pas l'interdit de le
faire c'est l'interdit d'en parler elle
est l'une des premières victimes
d'inceste à avoir témoigné à visage
découvert et va Thomas c'était en 1986
sur le plateau de l'émission Les
Dossiers de l'écran si vous voulez ça
n'a aucun sens si votre père devient
votre amant une nuit pour devenir votre
père le lendemain matin sans qu'un seul
mot soit prononcé et va Thomas a mis du
temps avant de se souvenir de ce viol
heureusement j'ai été agressé à 15 ans
les personnes qui avaient été agressées
beaucoup plus jeune enfant alors le
l'amnésie est beaucoup plus importante
alors que moi j'étais quand même sûre
qu'il s'était passé quelque chose au
moment de son témoignage à la télé elle
vient de fonder l'association SOS
inceste et de sortir un livre le viol du
silence dans lequel elle brise et
l'omerta j'ai tout de suite dit
moi je veux pas qu'on cache je veux
parler à visage découvert parce que je
veux dire ce que j'ai vécu pour que les
autres puissent parler aussi ce qui me
semblait important c'était de créer un
réseau de parole de se rencontrer entre
nous etc c'est des ça qui me semblait
important son témoignage entraîne des
réactions de téléspectateurs un
ingénieur qui nous dit j'ai des
relations quotidiennes avec ma fille de
13 ans pourquoi empêchez-vous les gens
d'être heureux un agent technique qui
dit on commence ou comment c'est fini
l'inceste j'ai une fille de 10 ans que
j'aime caresser et je me demande si mes
impulsions sont coupables c'était ce qui
était le discours
comment dire
général une fois je suis tombé sur un
homme
qui a téléphoné à l'association en
disant mais qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous nous embêtez
exactement ce que de ce que disait cet
homme à l'émission moi je suis heureux
avec ma fille etc etc je dis monsieur
expliquez-moi ce que vous faites à votre
fille alors je l'ai fait parler j'ai dit
Monsieur ça ça vaut 10 autres prisons
c'est interdit par la loi alors il a
raccroché moi je pense qu'en train
parent et un enfant il n'y a pas
d'inceste heureux en tout cas pour
l'enfant c'est pas vrai
il y a une telle toute puissance des
parents par rapport à l'enfant c'est pas
possible le témoignage des vatomas a
permis à d'autres victimes de se livrer
moi quand je parlais après dans d'autres
émissions j'étais portée par toutes les
autres qui avaient qui témoignaient et
tout ça j'étais à un moment donné je me
sentais le porte-parole de celle qui
nous avait écrit d'ailleurs dans des
lettres des femmes disaient s'il vous
plaît lisez
être à la radio aujourd'hui Eva Thomas
est membre de la civise la commission
sur l'inceste elle porte ce message
d'espoir si vous trouvez les bonnes
aides vous aurez appris une belle vie
voilà c'est
on n'est pas victimes à vie c'est juste
un passage extrêmement douloureux mais
croyez que la vie elle vous attend elle
est aussi pleine de cadeaux et de
surprises
[Musique]